[Music]
think what what many of our viewers also
don't know seven years ago when we made
our first video that was actually on a
channel called editing sports Emma
wanted to try out his editing skills I
had got like an interest to do some
editing on the videos since first videos
it was only me an ml while filming a
filming our training session we were
doing all sorts of fun trick shots
Emma was trying out a lot of things with
all sorts of effects and it yeah it was
a very interesting you can say the first
video it became quite evident that
people were more instanceid actual
tricks that my victim still so yeah I
think it didn't take many videos when I
started to leave out those special
effects and we were actually more
focusing on the tricks themselves we
realized that it was the trick shots
people liked so we did another one and
that's where I came in for the first
time I was impressed by the editing
editing of the videos but the tricks
were so so good I figured I had to jump
in and saw Saints hair skills me and
Emma we played in the same club when
we're juniors
and north of he was from a different
city but they're also known no not the
for a long time
[Applause]
[Music]
our first viral video was ping-pong next
finisher extinguisher extinguisher the
candle a candle shot shutting down the
candle for 100k our biggest focus was on
the challenge confidency series this is
the series where you challenge us with
the craziest ideas related table tennis
which is a super nice way to interact
with the audience you get crazy ideas
some of them are absolutely ridiculous
[Music]
I thought we get so much inspiration and
ideas from the comments some of them are
actually really difficult to pull off
even for us I think the fact that we we
all play Tilton's at a high level really
makes it possible for us to do some of
the challenges we get
[Applause]
I think it was 2018 that's when we
started to make videos almost weekly
before that it was we had no plan we
were just whenever we felt like it would
pursue the video which was wasn't very
often we're thinking but let's give this
channel a chance and let's see where it
takes us
[Music]
when we reached 100k subscribers it was
really massive for us we never we never
really thought with it we could possibly
reach 100,000 subscribers it felt really
good and special and like we achieved
something big that really was a was a
big thing for us we do a really special
video for that and I did idea was to
play one rally with 100 different items
and we do it's gonna be hard first of
all to find hundred items and bring them
to the hall and then yeah filming it was
it was a nightmare
it took so long it wasn't really fun
there were few tries where we messed up
and like 90 plus items and because it
took so long to organize the things so
after every attempt it took at least 50
minutes to get everything back on the
table and then when it was the last shot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
record cover or some table and the ball
dropped on the racket cover and we
thought that we missed it we thought no
that was 99 we ruined it
[Applause]
we thought it was 99
in the end we got it it was only just
over a year ago when we hit one that's
really it's crazy ya see the goal for
2019 rested it 1 million
we had about 230,000 so it was a long
way long way to 1 million we mentioned
in one of our videos in the beginning of
2019 that and don't forget to subscribe
to help us reach 1 million subscribers
yeah it was to be honest it was quite
ambitious
so we did 300k and it was 24 mile and
Micah's Walter throw down we had a lot
of requests see us playing against each
other because we haven't shown that in a
video yet so that was the first match
[Music]
[Applause]
joy after you know I lost that one but I
had to say it was some purpose so that
Miko would accept the challenge for the
500k soul of this one but I'm sure I
beat you in a best-of-seven yeah I want
that set and that set the challenge for
the 500k big match and to make things a
bit more interesting thought the loses
our cutters beard and if I lose we'll
get to shave my head I think you
wouldn't have accepted it if I would
have warned him so I had to lose on
purpose I can talk and always lose well
said to me we hadn't done that sort of
stuff before some sketches and comedy
stuff so we had been like postponing the
idea for some time but then we
eventually got like the courage to to
try out something totally different than
something totally new we weren't quite
sure how it work out but it was it was
really fun to film and you really need
to get out of your comfort zone and do
something special for example screaming
I can't do this I'm not really a
screamer ready uh-huh I'm not ready I'll
need some water it's me I remember it
was a super fun video to film and we
were like laughing all the time when we
were filming the video
[Music]
we had a really fun idea to do the
intros in different languages it was fun
it was fun at first
guten tag we've done it the hot gates a
helped a lot
gotcha ha mina-san konnichiwa everybody
obviously wanted us to do our intro in
your language so the comments section
was literally flooded with comments that
do the intro in German do the intro in
Polish do the intro in my language and
we stopped getting actual challenge
requests
everything was just about the language
intro so we thought okay okay this has
to stop I have to stop doing this now
the comment section has calmed down and
we're guessing good good challenge ideas
again Seneca 500k and it's a big much
between me and my account
we had a big punishment for the loser
which was for me it was shaved my head
and forth I was to shave his beard I
have to say I was rooting for me just
because I think it's worse to lose the
hair then its loosing the the beard
I've played off to so many times and
this time it was it was just different
Mika really likes to get nervous on
those big matches stuff I know I
wouldn't really have any huge problems
losing him what a shot
I've probably never been so nervous in
the table tennis match in my whole - I
didn't want to lose my hair I wanted to
see up there without bit know what
having fun of course I want it's pretty
easily but I just remember one points he
somehow like fell down on the floor
never seen the movie so fast it was so
funny to see like he was serious
business for him period that imagine you
see that sometimes from me when I really
fights and they may want to lose my
beard during the whole match it felt
like Ottawa's on
he was on top of Ireland we just didn't
have any chance it was so scared to lose
his hair so I got my head shaved off
looks pretty nice yeah free haircut
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the many cool ideas we've gotten
all synchronized table tennis I think
that's one of the coolest videos that we
have actually done on our Channel
[Applause]
something something we've never seen
before we've never tried one that's
actually one of the most interesting
things about doing these videos is
getting to try stuff that's never been
tried before and not knowing how it's
gonna work and this synchronized
sentence with one of those things it's
one of those videos that we thought that
would be super cool for the audience to
watch but it just didn't turn out so
popular in addition to this sync one of
the videos that we thought would do
really whoo hell was the bubble bursting
video that was again like super cool to
make or for some reason it wasn't so
popular and then on the other hand there
are those videos that we think that this
is not even worth publishing and then
that goes like gets millions of views so
you never really know for sure like
what's what's a good video 600k we did
triangle tailors the triangular table
tennis is one of those examples that we
were thinking that the true we even like
publish this video we had messed up the
microphones so the audio quality was
really bad and I think it has maybe a
couple of million abuse up to date yeah
that was that was interesting and that's
I think also that proves that it's too
good to sometimes try out some new stuff
on the channel because he might do well
and even start a theory for the channel
then we hit 700k subscribers and to Lake
Lake ping-pong was quite a big projects
by far one of the funnest project we're
done it was first of all super cool but
it was super difficult also to arrange
so we spent there actually one week and
the amount of time it took to film one
trickshot unlike when it was so much
longer than normal trickshot because we
had the Sun it was always shining from
the wrong direction I know that the Sun
is coming yeah so you can see anything
and then we have the wind that's a way
it's a bit for the wind so here we are
on a lake waiting for the wind to blow
away because if there's even like a bit
of the wind in the middle of the lake
there's no possibility to actually play
there it's just a moves back yeah he's
strong when the raft like creeping away
all the time he has to be like we had to
get it to the same spot again and we had
one camera on a boat and the wind was
blowing the boat this direction the raft
this direction it was just yeah it's
blowing you away don't go we had kept on
kept on having to go and pick pick up
the ball from the lake there's so many
things that were just doing it's very
difficult for us to see on the video oh
now the floor is slippery but luckily we
had our friend Patrick helping
yourselves it was really really cool
when we were able to play in the middle
of the lake I was so much fun we had we
did a lot of filming and then we we had
a sauna every night and we had a lot of
fun at the cottage that that week super
cool project really happy that we made
it then we hit 800k internal image
towards a swollen child table we thought
if me and ml both play at the same time
against Arthur then we're gonna have a
chance to win I would like to say that I
will share our than a beer tempered to
be honest I really thought I would list
well going into that match I didn't
believe that author would have any
chance to win that a match against me me
and Mika but how wrong can a person be
we didn't have any chance but we thought
I would be like crazy advance if you
have two against one by ended up we're
just messing messing each other up and
authors just flying to the middle and
neither of us knew who would take the
ball and what's interesting tryout but
yeah surprise the bad result yeah we
realized that 1 million is coming a lot
faster than we thought we really wanted
to make this video special so hope you
guys don't mind that we're posting it a
few weeks later yeah all these years
there's been so many fun moments at
least most of the time bring it on
it has been some painful jackpot moments
yeah things don't always go as planned
[Music]
[Music]
here we are 1 million subscribers
reaching 1 million subscribers felt
really special and incredible
it felt really amazing hitting 1 million
I think there is two parts reaching that
milestone the first one being that when
you have worked for something really
hard so many years and when you
eventually reach that goal
it feels really incredible that you have
managed to pull it off there's been a
lot of hard work put to these videos
during during the years but I think even
more importantly the fact that seeing so
many people like being happy for us made
it like really really memorable and was
also kind of like it was touching to see
that the channel means so much to so
many others too than just us 3 huge
thanks to you guys because it's really
it's really special to hear hear these
positive comments from from you and and
that means so much to you as as well as
us thank you so much everybody for your
continuing support for watching our
videos and commenting your ideas there
has been such a big inspiration for us
that really is the reason why we make
these videos it's amazing to have 1
million of you guys following our
channel very happy if you guys enjoy
this - here - not next targets let's say
targets for 2020 20 is 16 million
[Applause]
IIIi think it's possible just to
remember to subscribe we can do it we
can make we can make sixteen video okay
but honestly 50 million okay okay let's
listen and now that we've reached 1
million doesn't mean that we're gonna
stop we're gonna keep doing new videos
trying to come up with new ideas and
we're really looking forward to the
future